welcome to this video mr. danger okay
let's play mr. danger from from from
Spain and it's a dutch defense yeah g5
is a possible move while the sea hmm
really what about efore here what are
you playing on you for Queen age five
this is Wow relief you can go to d8 come
on let's let's wait for just a moment
okay he's got g6 is a g6 I understand
but I can take Here I am okay let's
let's do that what a crazy position okay
now i can give the check but it's
probably not helping much so i must
develop and protect the rook if he takes
on d4 with the Queen I plane I gf3
taking just taking another temple
protecting h4 yeah this is a fantastic
compensation of course for the pawn I'm
not even I'm bad upon down okay we can
lose track easily and this this wacky
position okay just just get the pieces
out he's never going to get into safety
anyway with the skin ok Knight e5
blunders the bishop sound probably not
mmm castles group be one Queen B 1 they
all know cotton ok let's castle
yeah okay 95 takes on these three and
the Queen check yeah that's a it's
winning the rope here yeah that's
probably probably okay I mean if you
only move the Queen and pawns it should
it should be there should be some
punishment for that so he takes on d3
Queen h5 check king d 8 and then just
night f7 I guess check move the king and
then I just take the rook yeah it's it's
simple and good and at the end of all
this I threaten Queen f7 to win the the
somewhat silly looking at eight bishop
again now he's taking time it's a bit
too late I guess
yeah I really don't think black and can
save this anymore yes this one let's ah
let's take here takes Bishop takes and
I'm threatening Bishop f7 check made
this is quite a threat let's see what is
flex reply yeah does he dare to move the
piece he has not done this yet so not
sure 97 maybe nope
okay so what now I thought Queen d5
might be a good one there should be five
it's a quite and let's not just let's
just play that and not spend ages on the
move it's probably strong anyway this
should be five wins the Queen and it's
it's a big threat anyway
on the move lucky 600 I go Quinn d8 mate
okay let's see look do you all know mr.
something better thread is now just 97
97 27 Bishop b5 winning and I'm not sure
that he has a defense I mean I'm not
sure as a weird way to phrase it I don't
see a move really what should you do
moving the bishop on the 7s Queen d8
mate and what what what should we do now
at f5 I can click we have seven Queen a
55 everything else fails yeah this is
something better now carrots it's enough
it's really enough
black resigns yeah mr. danger he
endangered himself pretty quickly yes c5
I don't really don't really think you
can afford that stuff I think the black
black smooth yes g5 sorry it's g5 which
also looks a bit crazy but it's it's
it's okay efore I'm sorry II form can
lead to dangerous play Queen h5 mate and
black has funky move rock age 7 which is
and it seems entirely unclear really
weird move but this is a this is a line
and after this is also possible after
this something like like that maybe I
would have played that because I don't
know if all really well or not say at
all I only know that II for gage 7 is a
complete mess and while he played that
move and I think this is just unplayable
I mean this is a really substantial what
what what should you do I think this is
the only move really and then I mean I
cannot believe that um ok computer
suggests knight c6 CM this might be an
idea the idea is this k little trick so
I need to probably just develop yeah I
mean this is just just bad for the king
and just play this Knight f3 Bishop d3
of course he can take now here for
example but it's just it's just not good
this yeah I have a hard time to believe
really
again after that black is just just lost
compass on plaza form here here this
should be 2m is simple and good okay but
this is also also probably good enough
plus 5 okay i overlooked Queen takes h5
you okay but this is also what is it
plus 9 Queen B 70 but ok just ajust a
straight attack for for nothing done
yeah the Dutch defense is an opening
value where you really if you commit one
one serious blunder one mistake it
really costs you the game directly I
mean it of course in somewhat more
classical openings like the the Queens
gambit or something you you might get
into trouble if you make a mistake but
you not not loose straight away and in a
somewhat tube online opening us the
dutch i'm not saying better opening it
just a bit risky you tend to lose
straight away because of your king
position or your weaknesses okay thanks
for watching